[موسيقى]
في الذكرى الثانيه عشره لاندلاع الثوره
باسامين تقطون خطوه جديده تجاه ما يصف
الرئيس قيس سعيد بجمهوريه جديده وذلك
بانتخاب مجلس جديد للنواب للسبعه عشر من
هذا الشهر وذلك بعد اقرار دستور الجديد
جرى الاستفتاء عليه في الخامسه والعشرين
من يوليو الماضي قبل ذلك بعام بدا مسار
سياسي جمد فيه سعيد البرلمان المنتخب ثم
حله وازاحد الصوره عام 2014 وكل ما افرزه
من هياكل حكم تعدديه وصما اداءها من خلل
والفساد قدوه ترى فيها هو المعارضه
التونسيه تاسيسا لديكتاتوريه جديده
واقتداءا بنظام زين العابدين بن علي في
هذه الاجواء من التوتر السياسي والتازم
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي للانتخابات النيابيه
يصفها الاتحاد التونسي والعمل للش لانها
بلا طعم ولا لون غيره ان انصار سعيد
يعملون ان تعيد سلطات الدوله الى العمل
وفي انتظار ما تؤول اليه تشكيله مجلس
وبالمرتقب يضر تساؤل عن مصير النواب
البرلمان الذي كان حصتنا الليله الصيف
وبالشعب نحاول تقصي اثر عدد من النواب
السابقين وقد تعرضوا لملاحقات امنيه
وقضائيه ومنع من العلاج او السفر او حتى
العوده الى اعماله السابقه وهي اجراءات لم
يسلم منها حتى بعض من اساسه والمسؤولين
السابقين نسكمل بقيه قصتنا مع ضيفنا جوهر
بن مبارك القضيه في صلاه الخلاصه المعارضه
وكمان مارس القياده في التيار الشعبي
نساله ضيفينا عن الدوافع الحقيقيه وراء
هذه الاجراءات والملاحقات ولماذا نالت من
شخص
ساسه وشخصيات حتى من المحسوبين على داعمه
قصص عياد وجدول لجوء هو بالمجلس المنحل
الى محكمه حقوق الانسان الافريقيه لتاجيل
الانتخابات المقبله وهل مجلس النواب
الجديد كافن في ظل صلاحيته المحدوده
للتعبير عن امال الشعب التونسي ورفع
المعاناه عنه لكن لنشاهد قصه اولا ونبدا
بعدها الحوار
[موسيقى]
التخذت
جمله
فورا الق
يتمثل في تجميد كل اختصاصات المجلس
النيابي
قائمين بواجبهم
انهم في مكانهم لحطوا فيه الشعب اللي هو
نواب
عن كل اعضاء المجلس النيابي
[تصفيق]
البرلمان اغلق بدبابه لم يغلق بالاستور لم
يغلق بالشام لاغلق بدبابه عسكريه
[تصفيق]
الجماهير
وينحاز الى مطالبهم
[تصفيق]
هنا كان نواب الشعب قبل الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو 2021 يعملون في ثاني مجلس
النيابي بعد ثوره 2011 اختارهم الشعب في
انتخابات السادس من اكتوبر 2019
تعذيبا لتجربه الانتقال الديمقراطي وليكون
صوته النابض بتطلعاته وانتصاراته تبخر
برلمان 2019 عن فوز حركه النهضه بثلاث 53
مقاطع ثلتها الكتله الديمقراطيه بس 37
مقالا وحسب قلب تونس 28 القادم لليهما
ائتلاف الكرامه والحزب الدستوري الحر
فسيفساء من الكتل الحزبيه اسفرت عن تجاذبت
سياسيه وصراعات الجيولوجيا القت بثلالها
على الراي العام التونسي
فاذا عدنا الى الارقام الى المقارنات نجد
ان اداء المجلس الذي تم تجميده ثم حله
افضل من المجلس الذي سبقها ولكن صوره
المجلس اا وخاصه صراع الحاد بين بعض
النواب مع رئيس المجلس هذا الذي اعطى همم
صوره اختصرت في جمله واحده هو مجلس السب
والشتم والعراق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مخدومه معموله وتجيب اصوات وتجيب
برشاج على الفيس بوك طلعت ماذا يتوقف
الذين يقومون بها عن ذلك وكان هذا يخفي اي
عمل
جديرين واصبحت الامور المضاده ده وانت في
الدوري الطبقه السياسيه المجلس النواب
حديث ولا في السياسي وما فيهوش حديث في
العمق الاقتصادي وما يترتب عليه من رفاه
اجتماعي للمواطنين كانت مواطن تونسي
موضوع سامر هتشيله فيديو يمشي
انا كانت هناك بعض الاخطاء التكتيكيه او
الفنيه او ردود الافعال ربما غير
المتناسبه او المنفلته ولكن اطلاقا
لم تكن مبررا لما حدث ولم تكون هي السبب
وانما كانت نتيجه لمن منعنا من العمل لقد
منعنا من العمل احتضنت الصراعات السياسيه
تحت قبه البرلمان واثرت التجاذبت بين كتله
على مناخ العمل النيابي فبادره اصوات داخل
المجلس بمحاولات التغيير الحلول من داخل
المدرسه احنا في همم
2020 اختي حبينا نعمل سحبه ثقه من رئيس
مجلس النواب قلنا رئيس مجلس النواب ولا
عنوان ازمه بحيث لا يمكن ان يكون هنا
شخصيه جامعه لكل مكونات المجلس كان
بالامكان نزعل الفتيل منذ البدايه لانها
شخصيه السيد راشد الغنوشي لا تتركه احد
على الحياه
وله معادون بشكل همم قاطع لكن الحل الذي
بدل البعض قارب نجاه لمسار البرلمان لم
يكتب له النجاح لتبقى الاوضاع على حالها
هذا ان لم تصبح اسود
سقطت لائحه سحب الثقه من رئيس نادي
الزمالك
فالمسؤوليه مشتركه بين الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه والبرلمان من جهه ورئيس
الجمهوريه من جهه اخرى ولكن في تقديري
مسؤوليه رئيس الجمهوريه كانت اكبر لانه
كان يبيت منذ البدايه تغذيه الازمه
والاستفاده منها الازمه التي عاشها على
وقعها
الاخر التوتر العلاقه بين قطبي مبنى
البرلمان وقصر قرطاج التوتر اعتبره
الكثيرون صراعا حول من له اليد العليا في
الدوله ومن يمثل الرجل القوي في البناء
رئيس الجمهوريه اصبح مع الايام لا يرى في
رئيس حركه النهضه مجرده رئيس البرلمان وان
ما بمثابه رئيس جمهوريه مكرر همم يسافر
الى الخارج ويستقبله رؤساء الدول وله
بمثابه العلاقات الخارجيه الموازيه
هو بالنسبه همم
راشد الغنوشي كان يعتقد انه رئيس الجمهوري
يمشي يكون في قبضه يده
على اساس انه حزب سياسي
الرجل يعني عنده همم التدين
الطبيعي بتاع التوانسه كل فيمكن ان يحتويه
وان يضعه تحت امرته وتولي تونس تحكم من
مجلس النواب مش من قصر قرطاج ولا من همم
قصر القسمه اصبحت سياسه الشد والجذب
العنوان الابرز في المشهد العام التونسي
وتفاقمت الازمه السياسيه والاقتصاديه في
ظل تفشل سريعا لفيروس كورونا وبطئ في جنب
طلاقه من الخارج واحتجاجات تطالب بتناح
الحكومه
انتزعت الحكومه بشكل من الاشكال ثم بعد
ذلك بدا استهداف النواب وحرمالهم من
الجوازات جوازات السفر الدبلوماسيه ثم بعد
ذلك راينا كيف رفض امضاء القوانين ثم بدا
يعلن عن تراسه لكل الاجهزه الامنيه فنحن
كنا نتوقع اشياء كثيره من هذا القبيل
وحذرنا منها التونسيين نعم هناك خطر داهم
حقيقي والخطر الداهم الحقيقي هو قيس سعيد
المنعطف السياسي الذي جاءت به اجراءات
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو 2021 قسم الراي
العام التونسيه الى قسمين
مناصر لاجراءات قيس سعيد وقسما رافض منتد
منعطف لم يرسم نقطه نهايه لبرلمان 2019
فحسب لكنه فتح قوس البدايه لمعاناته كانت
هناك مؤشرات سابقه همم تاكد ان رئيس
الجمهوريه يفكر في الانقلاب فعلا من خلال
خطابات الرئيس وقت متاخر من الليل
فالسكنات الامنيه ولا عسكريه من خلال
متابعه بعض التعيينات من خلال تعطيل العمل
الحكومي من خلال عدم بذل اي مجهود
للمساهمه في جلب التلاقيه من الخارج
لاثاره الراي العام ضد الحكومه فلما حصل
الانقلاب كانت الثوره همم مهيئه ولم يكن
هناك اي تعاطف لا مع الحكومه ولا مع
البرلمان وهم المستهدفين بشكل رئيسي
بالانفذه
بعد ذلك بايام نعرف انه بدات الموجه
الاولى من الهجمه اييي الامنيه والهجمه
السياسيه على النواب واا نتذكر انه يوم 30
جويليه بدات المداهمات وهتك الحرمات
ومحاصره البيوت وكل ذلك وادرج اسمي
بالتفتيش فاض اذكررت الى التخفي طيله شهر
كامل وكانت التهم التي وجهت الينا تهم همم
وحلنا بها على القضاء العسكري تهم منا وعد
التامر على امن الدوله وهمم السعي الى
تبديل هيئه الدوله
وحملوا الناس على التقاتل يعني تهام كلها
تؤدي وفقا لفصل 72 من مجله الجزائيه التي
تؤدي الى الاعدام
هكذا اصبحت بطاقات التفتيش والاحكام
المتكرره بالسجن والملاحقات القضائيه امام
المحاكم العسكريه سيفا مزلطا على الرقاب
النواب وهو ما دفع من بعض منهم الى الهجره
خوفا من ان القانون لم يعد هو الفيصل
بينهم وبين السلطه التنفيذيه فلما اعلنت
الانقلاب عندي ولد عمره ثلاث سنين
اتصلت له رد الفعل بتاعه
في الحبس
فاهم كل شيء
هل كان صدمه اعتقد اني كنت متصور الي بعد
10 سنين مستحيل
لكن مستحيل ليس التونسيين بالمعنى بالمعنى
الخايب هل عرفت اني بشان كنت متاكده
المحكمه العسكريه بتونس غيابيا بالسجن 10
اشهر على ياسين العياري النائب عن حركه
امل
بالبرلمان المنحل بتهما منها الاساءه الى
رئيس الجمهوريه وكان الغيار قد تم ايقافه
اياما قليله بعد اجراءات الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو واودي على السجن لمده شهرين على
اساس حكم قضائي عسكري سابق تم الافراج عنه
في سبتمبر
2021 غادر بعضها الى فرنسا للعلاج من
مخلفات سجده
ثم تعكرت حاله الوالده
وانا في فرنسا
وهو حي وهو ميت شوف حالك
ترجع
حكم المحكمه العسكريه ب 10 اشهر وفجرته
منعت من حضور
يرحمها كان الامر متوقعا وعاديه عشر اشهر
لم تغتسل ملاحقه عدد من نواب المجلس
المنحل على المحاكمات العسكريه بل طال
الجوانب اخرى من حياتهم اعتبروها امعانا
في التشفي منهم
2021 كل النواب بدون استثناء تعرضوا الى
تطبيقات كثيره ولكن هناك حالات انسانيه
جلبت الاهتمام وتستحق التوقف وخاصه النائب
مصطفى بن احمد الذي اضطر الاعتصام
بالمستشفى العسكري نظرا لرفض استعمال
تغطيه همم الصحيه وهي حق كل النائب وكل
مواطن همم نائب هاجر ابو هلال وحاليا
لطيفه الحباشي
مجلس منطقه اني نغير نقدر نغير شويه الوضع
تنموي بالتحديد التنموي في جهدي هدف سامي
بالنسبه لي اني نعمل حاجه
سيد الوزير كبير
تعليق احكي بالتعليق مع اني انا مش معروفه
برشا لكن الحب
وقت المعطنيش الدواء احساس واحد
انسان
[موسيقى]
والحرمان من العمل والتغطيه الاجتماعيه
والصحيه والمنع من السفر كانت ايضا من
نصيب نواب اخرين
معناها 30 مارس همم كنت همم مروحه من
المحكمه في التاريخ وقفتني دوريه امنيه
انت مراقبه همم السياره
ااا حد ثاني على الحاسوب قال لي استاذ هكر
كلك حمره شبيك اش عندك يا استاذه شو عندك
قلت له والله شو نقول لك عشان شنو اللي
عندي انا همم نائبه خدمت الشعب همم عشر
سنين خدمت بلادي ودولتي عشر سنين هاذا
وانت باش كيف اذتني بعدها ما انام مباشره
في همم بعدها باسبوعين ااه اكتشفت انه عن
مصابه بمرض خطير جدا مرض نادر ورم همم
سرطان في الدماغ همم هي تتطلب وبحت
الفحوصات وغيره وغيره يعني
ليش الوحيد فيه هو هو العلاج لما نوع من
الاشعه ال همم الخاصه
حرمانها من جواز السفارها لذلك لم يكن
امام النائبه لطيفه الحباشي الا خوض معركه
نضاليه للحصول عليه ورغم انتصارها وحصورها
على الجواز الا ان سفارها يظل تحت ط
الاجراء الحدودي المعروف برمز اس 17
الحقوق اللي هي وثيقه معناها السفر
لم يكن امامهم سوى التمسك بشرعيتهم نيابيه
والانخراط في التحركات المعارضه للتدابير
الاستثنائيه واجراءات الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو 2021 حدثت حاله من الرقه
والبهت وشلل شلل سياسي وشلل ميداني ثم بدا
تعود تدريجيا المبادره الى قوه الشارع
الديمقراطي فتكون مواطنون ضد الانقلاب
تكثفت الاحتجاجات وشهدت الشوارع الرئيسيه
للغاصمه اكثر من مظاهرات ومسيره ضد حاله
الفراغ الدستوريه والتشريعي في البلاد
احتجاجاته تواصلت برفض عدد كبير من
الاحزاب المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه
القادمه في ما اعتبر عدد اخر من النواب ان
البرلمان ما قبل الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
هو جزء من الماضي وانا البرلمان الذي تعد
به انتخابات السابعه عشر من ديسمبر 2020
امر يقع لابد من التكيف معه السياسه
حاجتي تكون موجود يا تكون غائب لا تدار
السياسه بالكراسي الفارغه يعني انا ما
نصورش ان واحد يقول انا مليش في الشركه في
الانتخابات مش يكون عنده تاثير ايجابي على
الساحه السياسي ولتاثير ايجابي على تغيير
وقع التوانسه للافضل
بينما عندما تتكلم ولو صوتك لا يؤخذ به
وكلامك لا ياخذ به ما بمشي يكون عنده
الناس وفي يوم من الايام
والحمد لله اعتبر نفسي محظوظا انني كنت
حاضرا وكنت شاهد حق في اخر برلمان شرعي
برلمان ديمقراطي برلمان الثوره
باختيار الشعب وباصوات الشعر حقيقيه
كل هذا فورا شهداء شهداء من بابا الله
يرحمه
انتقل ديمقراط في مصاريف وصعوبات ودستور
وحرب على الارهاب يعني الاحساس بالمراره
على مسار كامل هل معناها ما قالوهون
بالعربي
من همم
معناها حتى وقت بعدين حتى انهم يرجعوا الى
الشغل متاح معناها الاصلي
ما قبل الخامس والعشرين مليون وما عاشها
نوابه بعد حله حجر عثره امام تنقيه
الاجواء السياسيه في تونس وهي تقبل على
موعد انتخابيه جديد عنوانه خرز اللا عوده
الى الورق
[موسيقى]
تونس اذن على مفترق طرق بين مسالين مسار
ترى فيه المعارضه تعبيرا عن شرعيه الثوره
وارثه دستور الديمقراطي استغرق اعداده
عامين في مجلس تاسيسه المنتخب مؤسس لنظام
برلمانيين ومسار يتبناه الرئيس قيس سعيد
منذ الخامس والعشرين من يوليو العام
الماضي هذا المسار تراه معرض انقبا وقد
بدا بتجميد البرلمان ثم حله ثم اقرار
دستور اشرف سعيد على وضعه ويرسي نظاما
رئاسيا ويحول السلطات التشريعيه والقضائيه
وتنفيذيه الى وظائف ويمضي هذا المسار خطوه
اضافيه خلال ايام الانتخابات مجلس نواب في
برلمان في صلاحيات محدوده حيث يعطي
الدستور للرئيس حق تعيين رئيس الوزراء
واعضاء حكومته وانكاميته اقالتها وكيف
يتمكن العلماء من اقاله الحكومه يتعين
تاييد ثلثي الاعضاء لحجم الثقه عنها دكتور
رئيسيا في اختيار الحكومات ويسحب الثقه
منها بتاييد نصف عدد النواب زائد واحد
البرلمان المرتقب الجديد يتكون من غرفتين
الاولى هي مجلس النواب الشعب المقرر
انتخاب وبعد ايام ويتالف من 101 الى 60
مقعدا واجر انتخاب اعضائه على اساس فردي
وليس عبر قائمه انتخابيه حزبيه اما الغرفه
الثانيه فهي مجلس يضم نوابا منتخبين عن
الجهات والاقاليم ويحدد القانون مهمه اما
البرلمان المنحنى فقد كان يتكون من غرفه
واحده هي مجلس النواب ويتكون من 27
يمكن الناخبين في اي دائره سحبت ثقه من
النائب في البرلمان الجديد اذا قصر في
مهمه او اخل بواجبه النزاهه وفق اجراءات
يحددها القانون لا يتمتع النائب بالحصانه
البرلمانيه فيما يتعلق بجرائم القذف
وتبادل العنف داخل المجلس اذا عطل اعماله
ولرئيس الحق في طرح مشروعات القوانين على
البرلمان خصوصا الماليه وكذا المعاهدات
الدوليه ولمشروعاته او لويه النظر اما
للنواب فلهم حق وعرض مقترحات القوانين
شرطه ان تكون مقدمه من 10 نواب على الاقل
ولرئيس الحق في حل البرلمان بمجلس سيء
بينما لم يتضمن الدستور بنودا لاقاله
الرئيس حيث يتمتعوا بالحصانه قيلته توليه
الرئاسه ولا يسال عن الاعمال التي قام بها
في اطار اداءه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام وبضيفين
الكريمين من تونس جوهر بن مبارك القيادي
في جبهه الخلاص والمعارضه وجمال مارس
القيادي في التيار الشعبي وهو من الاحزاب
المؤيده لخيارات الرئيس قيس سعيد منذ
الخامس
ان لا يتكرر ما حدث مع البرلمان السابق
البرلمان الجديد خاصه
العمليه الانتخابيه التي ستفرز هذا
البرلمان الجديد بانها بلا لون
مساء الخير تحيه لكافه المشاهد قناه
الجزيره
وصف برلمان بلا طعم ولا لون وهو الوصف
الذي ينطبق على الماء والماء ضروري لما
وصلت الحياه بعد ان تتوقفت الحياه او تكيت
في 24 جويليه لولا العشريه السوداء
البرلمان السابق الذي وصف بانه قد
تحصل على شهاده الدوليه هو برلمان الرئيس
السيسي والاقتصادي التي تحالفت مصالحها
بين حركه الاخوان وحزنا بالقرب وغيرهما عن
مطارده اليوم بالانتربول
وادى الى ذلك المهازل وتلك المنازل التي
رايناها من رشق الاموال ومن تبادل العنف
ومن على صالح ضد صالح المواطن واستنزاف
للماليه العموميه وغير ذلك كل ذلك يجعل
الذي نظرنا اليه ذلحين يلخص مسار 25
جويليه بكون محاكمات عسكريه بطاقات جلد
براد وبغير ذلك وهو ريبورتاج موجه وغير
موضوعي تماما
انت تقول بانهم موجه وغير الموضوع الصحفي
يجب ان يكون موضوع
يجب ان يكون موضوعيه ان ياخذ الراي الاخر
بصوره كليه بوضع ابصار 25
بيوجه بشكل كامل لاعطاء صوره قاتمه وسوداء
على المسار 25 جويليه محاكمات عسكريه
وبتقات جلد وامراض وغير ذلك
بصوره كليه هو انقاذ الشعب التونسي من
عشيره السواد والخراب هو انقاذ من بقي
القروي وغيره هو في قاده من الجهاز السري
والجهاز المالي لحضرتك الاخوان هو مسار
كامل وهو يعني رئيس الجمهوريه
من اجل انقاذ هذا الشعب وانقاذ البلاد
التي وصلت على حافه الهاويه يوم 24
اشبيليه على مستوى المالي والامني على
المستويات حركه الاخوان كانت مخترقه للامن
ولداخليه وللقضاء وجميع اجهزه الدوله تحت
يد الاخوان من حلقه مبالغه المحاكمات التي
تمت الى المعنى ذلك
حتى اخرى
عفوا دعنا نتحدث هنا نتبادل الاطراف
الحديث دون ان تغضب بان لا زال مدن لدينا
متسع من الوقت ولكن الحريه ان تدافع لكن
الفيلم كان متوازنا كانت توجد في وجهه
النظر الاخرى لانواب المؤيدين من همم من
همم الطرف الاخر ساعود اليك سيد همم جمال
مارس لكن يعني اعود او اتحول الان سيد
جوهر بن مبارك عندما تسمع هذا الكلام سيد
جوهر بن مبارك نتسائل حقيقه هل تودنسيون
صفحه هؤلاء النواب وهم يتاهبون اليوم
للخروج للانتخابات البرلمانيه يختارون
فيها بدل البرلمان الواحد اثنين
نعم شكرا على الاستضافه وشكرا لمعد هذا
التقرير رغم ان هناك بعض اللوم في ان
التقرير لم ياتي على كامل قتامه مشهد 25
جويليه وكل التجاوزات التي قام بها قيس
سعيد ونظام قيس سعيد لم ياتي على مساله
الاحتجاجات القيصريه
وغيرها من الانتهاكات المتعلقه بمنع
المواطنين من السفر والتضييق على
التظاهرات والتضييق على الاحزاب السياسيه
والتضيق على الجمعيات وتهديد قيس سعيد
لمنظومه المجتمع المدني وتمويل المجتمع
المدني هناك الكثير والكثير من التجاوزات
ونحن نحتفل باليوم العالمي لحقوق الانسان
همم
الانتهاكات التي قام بها قيس سعيد همم
لحقوق الانسان غير مسبوق فقد رقما واحدا
همم جاء على
منظمه هيومن رئيس ووتش عندما قالت بان
المحكمه العسكريه في تونس لم تحاكم هذا
القدر من المواطنين المدنيين في تاريخها
بحجم المحاكمات التي وقعت في ااا في مرحله
قيس سعيد عدد المحالين امام المحاكم
العسكريه غير مصروفون
او ما قالهم
لا اريد ان ادخل في في جدال عقيم مع
السرديه مشروخه متكرره صارت الحقيقه لماذا
لم يخرج التونسيون او اغلبيه التونسيين
للشارع للدفاع عن هؤلاء للمطالبه بحقوقه
هؤلاء النواب في تونس اليوم
تماما وهو يمضي قدمها في تطبيق هذه الرؤيه
للرئيس قيس سعيد
لا هذا غير صحيح هذا جزء من السرديه التي
يريد ان يروجها قيس سعيد وانصار والمطبلين
للانقلاب
وللاستبداد
لان الشارع التونسي وجزء مهم من الشعب
التونسي كان في الشوارع منذ اقل من تقرير
48 ساعه كانت جبهه الخلاص في تظاهره
بالالاف في الشوارع وهي التظاهره يعني لم
اعد احصيه ربما العشرين او الاكثر التي
ينزل فيها التونسيون الى الشوارع نحن
اخترنا منذ البدايه منذ تجربه مواطنون ضد
الانقلاب نهج المقاومه السلميه
الديمقراطيه القانونيه المعتمده على
التحركات همم والتظاهر والحق والحق في
التظاهر
ايضا على مستوى اخر
حقيقه ان كان همم هؤلاء فعلا همم
الدوله ولاجهتها ما اخذ عليهم لماذا لحتى
اشخاصا من المناصرين لمسار قيس سعيد
يعني هناك تضييق للحريات في ذكر الحقوق
الانسان وهناك ضرب الحريات والحال انه
يقول انهم يقومون بالتظاهر كله كل شهر وكل
اسبوع يعني حريه تتظاهر مضمونه وخرجوا الى
الشارع فقد يعني مثل ما اذكر ان رصيدهم
غير كافي وخرجوا فقد ب 4500 شخص وهذه
شخصيه الرسميه خلال
لو كانوا لهم قدره على تجليس الشارع
بالالاف لا افتكوا الشارع ولا كان همم
ناصر النواب المعزولين وغير ذلك ولكن
الشعب كله مع في اتجاه مسار 25 جويليه وفي
انتظارات 25 جويده وفي انتظارات
الانتخابات القادمه من اجل استكمال
النصارى بناء مسار 25 جويده من اجل انقاذ
ما هدم وما قرب العشريه الفارقه طبعا ما
تقول سؤالك ارجع الى سؤالك
اليوم القضاء بدا يتعافى والقضاء تتحصل
معنا اصبح في اكثر استقلاليه واكثر تعافي
وبالتالي هذا تطبيق للقانون سواء لكل من
الاجر ما في حق الشعب التونسي لكل ما
ارتكب الجرائد يحاكم بصوره طبيعيه وفى
جهاز الدوله
لماذا الاجراءات مانع من السفر فيما يخص
العلاج غير ذلك منع وعدم عوده البعض
لعملهم الاصلي من يرى مثل هذه الاجراءات
يتساءل لماذا تم القيام بها يعني مثل هذه
الاجراءات لم يتم حتما تحت غطاء القانون
نحن من حيث المبدا سواء كحزبه وكحقوقي
يقول اننا مع حوريه التنقل مع حريه
التعبير مع مع حقق كل مواطن التونسي في
الحصول على جواز السفاره ولكن طبعا هناك
معطيات امنيه تحت التربه ما تختفي عنا لا
ندركها بخصوص خطوره بعض الاطراف خطوره في
خصوص اتصالاتهم بالخارج بخصوص ما يقابونا
بهما هذا كل العمل الامني وقضائي تحجير
السفاره ليقوم باذن قضائي وليكون بقرار من
الداخل لي كذلك القاره نحن كذلك من حيث
المبدا ضد محاكمه المدنيين امام الحركه
العسكريه واذكيره في سيدتي ان من كان يحكم
طلال العشريه الفارقه هم حركه الاخوان
لماذا لم يقوموا بما او اصلاح ما خربه
فتره بن علي من محاكمه المدنيين امام
المحاكم عسكريه 10 سنوات كامله ولم يلقح
القوانين في اتجاه ده ما قراتها الدوله في
اتجاه ده بقراتها الاجراءات التقاضي في
اتجاه حمايه الحريات والافراد فقط انغمسوا
في نهب الدوله انغمسوا في اختراق اجهزه
الدوله الغمسوا في كل ملى في في انواع من
الفساد وكان عليهم ان يراجعوا هذه
القوانين التي وعضعها بالعلي وهي محاكمه
المدنيين امام المحاكم العسكريه النصوص
القانونيه اليوم تسبح بذلك ولكن نحن من
حيث المبدا ضد محاكمه المدنيين امام
محاكمه عسكريه همم انتم اثارتهم وسؤالي
الان همم السيد جوهر بن مبارك ان تقاطع
هذه الانتخابات اي ان تقصوا انفسكم
بانفسكم لماذا اثرتم هذا النهد النهج الذي
يراه البعض عقيما لماذا لم تناكف وتطالب
مثل ما ذكر السيد همم جمال همم مارس
وتواصلون في همم ربنا مطالبه بحقوقكم
كامله
لا سيدتي العقم كله هو في المشاركه في هذه
الانتخابات المزوره
نحن اولنا رفضنا المسار برمته منذ 25
جويليه رفضنا الاستشاره الالكترونيه
ورفضنا الفاشله ورفضنا الحوار المغشوش
ورفضنا الصياغه الانفراديه على المقاس
التي قام بها سعيد لنص الدستور بعد ان
التهمه دستور البلاد وانكل به تنكيلا
وكذلك رفضنا المشاركه في الاستفتاء الذي
تشرف عليه هيئه منصبه مزوره غير محايده
وغير مستقله وكذلك همم رفضنا المشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات ترشحا وحمله واقتراحا
واعلنا من الان انها انتخابات لن نعترف
بنتائجها ولن نعترف
بالمؤسسات المنبثقه عليها المساله اولا هي
مساله مبدئيه تتعلق بعدم قبولنا ان نكون
كشهود زور على عمليه انقلاب وعمليه التهام
همم رصيد الثوره التونسيه ونهج الانتقال
الديمقراطي نحن لسنا من الذين يقولون بان
الوضع كان ورديا وان الوضع كان جيدا كنا
من اكثر الناقدين
لعمليه الاخفاق والفشل في المتراكمه التي
وقعت في في عشريه الانتقال الديمقراطي
ولكننا لا يمكن ان نكون شهود زهور على
عمليه بناء استبداد قادم وعمليه استحواذ
شعبه على السلطه وتنكيل بحريه التونسيين
وبعد ذلك بكرامتهم لان الازمه السياسيه
التي خلقها قيس سعيد همم الغير مسبوقه
تحولت الان الى ازمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
يعاني منها التونسيون الامرين هذا الذي
غير مهجه الشعب التونسي الان منذ اشهر
نعاين بالارقام والنوعين بالمعاينه الحسيه
ان المهجه العامه حابه التونسي صارت او ان
حازت عن قيس سعيد
وابتعدت عن همم
برنامج قيس سعيد ومسار قيس سعيد ولذلك نحن
اليوم نقول بانه هناك انقسام حاد داخل
المجتمع التونسي وداخل الشعب التونسي فيلم
المسار الذي يدعو الى اي قيس سعيد
كامل
ويحملون المعارضه بانها هي ايضا لم تكن في
المستوى همم هذا الحدث ولم يعني تعرف
مفاتيح اللعبه الديمقراطيه ولم تحافظ على
هذه الديمقراطيه وهي تتباكى عليها الان
لا لا هذا غير صحيح هذا خطاب عدني كل
الشعوب التي عرفت انتقالا الديمقراطيا
عرفت مثل هذه الكبوات ومثل هذه التراجعات
والمثل هذه الاخفاقات فقط الشعوب التي
صبرت ورابطت وراء وتمسكت بمسارها
الديمقراطي بمسار البناء الديمقراطي رغم
هذا هذه التعثرات هي التي نجحت في النهايه
في بناء دول القانون ودول ديموقراطيه تنتج
الرخاء وتنتج الكرامه لشعوبها وشعوب التي
لم تصبر
وسادت فيها هذه السرديات العدميه هي التي
اخفقت في نهايه الامر وتحول اخفاقها في
الانتقال الديمقراطي الى بناء الاستبداد
والى انقسامات ادت احيانا الى حروب وتقاح
بين داخل هذه المجتمعات اعتقد من المعارضه
تقوم تسير في طريقها الصحيح بانها الان
تراكم تراكم همم القوه من اجل
قاعد تونسيين والتونسيات بان الطريقه الذي
يسير في قيس سعيد والطريق الخطا واعتقد ان
ان نجحنا نجاحا كبيرا في هذا ولهذا اعتقد
ان تكون منخفضه يعني اتحول بهذه النقطه
لضيفنا سيد جمال مارس يعني هناك من يرى
بان الارقام ليست في صالح نهج الرئيس قيس
سعيد ولم تكن يوما في صالحه ويتوقع ان
تشهد هذه الانتخابات كم انتخابات سابقه
فتورا وعدم اقبال من التونسيين هناك ما
اخر كثيره في الواقعه يتحدث عنها البعض
منها نظام انتخابه الرئيس على اساس فردي
اقصاء الاحزاب والنظام القوائم فتح الباب
لشراء التزكيات الترشح على اسس القبليه
وفتح المجال الاثرياء القادرين على تمويل
حملاتهم ويرون في كل ذلك اعاده انتاج
لمنظومه قديمه خبيرها وساره عليها تونسيه
طبعا يعولوا اعداء مسار 25 جويليه على فشل
انتخابات 17 ديسمبر وضعف المشاركه من خلال
ما يفتعلونه من محاوله يعني
دفع المواطن الى العزوف زياده على الواقع
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي الذي هو مخلفات
العشريه السوداء من خلال نهب الماليه
العموميه ومن خلال ممارسه الاحتكار على
مستوى المواد الاساسيه حتى يعزف المواطن
على العمل السياسي طبعا هذه كل عوامل يعمل
من اجلها وينتظر من خلالها 25 جنيه لان
يتم العزوف لكن في خصوص بذكرته الكريمه
والضحين انتقال اذا ذم الافراد هو لم ياتي
به قيس سعيد بنفسه نحن كحز التيار الشعبي
كنا تواجهنا بهذا الطلب الى رئيس
الجمهوريه منذ اكثر من سنه ونصف بضروره في
وضع حدد البرلمان الماعز الذي سيت 2019
وخاصه بتغيير النظام السياسي بنظام
برلماني نظام سياسي وكذلك نظام الانتخاب
من نظام القوائم في دوره واحده الى نظام
الافراد على دورتين لان اين فيه همم
النظام الاكثر قرب من المواطن التونسي
والاكثر نجاعه والاكثر تمثيليه للموتن
التونسي على مستوى دائره جغرافيه تكون
اصغر حتى يكون عامل القرب وحتى لا تخلص من
ذلك التحالف ضمن للقوه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه لاصحاب الريع السياسي
والاقتصادي من خلال الفعل المالي السياسي
البرلمان سيدتي هو الذي كان نتاج الى قوى
المال السياسي التي فعل بشكل مفضوح امام
ضعف هيئه الانتخابات الفارده وهؤلاء اعرج
على ما سمعته من طيحين من قول هذه الهيئه
المنصبه بهذه الايه غير منصه تتضمن النصف
من خلال اعضاء خيره الاعضاء السابقين في
الايات السابقه في الوحده او هيئه 2014
وهي كلهم اعضاء تحسر على تزكيه السابقه
وكذلك عدد من القضاه رشحهم مجلس العلاقه
ولا نعرف ان المجلس على هذا هو من يمسكه
ملف القضاه ويعرفوا السيره السيره القاضي
وبالتالي
هذا الاعضائهم تحت رقابه المجلس على قضاء
هذه الايه اللي اعتبرها اكثر استقلاليه
واكثر حياد بالهيات السابقه رغم انها
مخترقه من حالات الاخوان من خلال الموظفين
الذين داخلها لان نعرف اغلب الموظفين
تقريبا
واغلبهم وانتدب خلالها العشريه الفارطه
وبالتالي
وجهنا ملاحظاتنا وانتقاديتنا في اكثر من
مره على هيئه الانتخابات ان تلقي هؤلاء
الاعضاء وان تكون حذره في خصوص انتدابات
رؤساء مراكز الاقتراع واعضاء الرقابه
وغيرها لاننا راينا مروان تدل على ان هذه
الهيئه المخترقه في اكثر من مناسبه
المشاركه وعود اليها همم
ان هذا البرلمان لا يمثل همم كل نواب
بالضروره الشعب التونسي سوفاصل قليلا يعني
الواقع يفرض تساؤل ربما عن مدى ومكان هذا
همم الدعم الذي يتحدث عنها انصار رئيس قيس
سعيد لتصحيح مسار الثوره همم هناك دوائر
الواقع بلا مرشحين هناك دوائر سيفوز فيها
مرشحون بالتزكيه اي انهم لن يمروا على
الانتخابات ولن ينتخبهم احد ولم يترشحوا
اصلا همم وهناك ايضا من يتحدث بان وفق
البيانات المعلنه للهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات سبعه دوائر مثلا لم يتقدم فيها
مرشحون 10 دوائر بمرشح واحد وثمان دوائر
بمرشحين اثنين فقط ما قولكم في كل ذلك ما
الذي يمكن ان يفرزه هذا
ويؤثر على شكل البرلمان المرتقب
كل تجربه سياسيه جديده طبعا فيها جوانب
ايجابيه وفيها بعض الاخطاء نحن كحز التيار
الشعبي كنا وجهنا انتقاداتنا الى هذا
القانون في جوانب وعينه منها شرط التزكيات
مجهفا وعده ربما الى ما ذكرته مضحين وجود
دوائر انتخابيه بدون مترشحين نظر لصعوبه
جمع هذه التزكيات خاصه بالخارج واغلب هذه
الدوائر هي بالخارج كذلك بس قالت
الوجود دوائر مترشح واحد هناك يقول طبعا
ان العيب ربما في المواطنين الذين لم
يترجح ولم يترشحوا بشكل الكافي ولما يكون
لهم معناها في دوائرهم في معتمديتهم ان
يكون معناها بالعدد الكافي في هذه
الترشحات لكن هذا لا ينفي ان هذا القانون
في عديد من النقاط الايجابيه التي يمكن ان
تخلق برلمان من ضمن وعلاقتها السياسيه
التي قد تقدمنا بهذه الجمهوريه فقدمناها
في مختلف الادواتنا هو التمثيل فئات
اجتماعيه اخرى خلافا الى الفئات التي
رايناها سابقا ان نمثل لا صغار حرفين ان
نمثل صغار موظف ايه الطلبه العاطلين على
العمل هؤلاء في هلايات شعبيه وشرائح
اجتماعيه واسعه من حقها ان تكون ممثله
داخل البرلمان القادم ولكن ربما هناك همم
على مستوى نوعيه المترشحين احيانا هناك
عدد محدود تقريبا كنا نعرف هو اكثر 40,000
مترشح سابقا اليوم فما 1440 مترشح وهذا
يعود الى نظام الاقتراع طبعا والى صعوبه
صعوبه شروط تترشح احيانا ولكن هذا لا يمنع
من الان انتظر من البرلمان القادم ان يكون
برلمان نوعيا من حيث تمثيليته لفئه
الشعبيه ضعيفه من خلال الروح الوطني التي
تتضمن خاصه ان اغلب المرشحين وعدد كبير
المترشحين هم المسترده 25 جميلا يتفاعلون
على مسار كامل في روح وطنيه عاليه من اجل
قطعه مع العشريه القادمه و من اجل تكريس
قام عليه مثلا 25 جميلا كالتكريس السياده
الوطنيه قد استقلال الوطني كامل ويل تنموي
خلق جديد وغير من العناصر التي قام
سيد جوهر بن مبارك سيد جوهر يعني همم
تقولون بان لا احد همم ربما سيتقدم لهذه
الانتخابات وان الشعب سيقاطعها وشرائح
عديده ليست موافقه عليها لكن كيف تفسر
اقدام 17 نائبا من برلمان 2019 غالبيتهم
من حزبي نداء تونس وقلب تونس اقدامهم على
الترشح في هذه الانتخابات بعضهم اعتبر
اصلا فائزا
تفسير في هذا يوم مجرد هذا قرارهم همم
الشخصي وليست همم ولم يكونوا لان النواب
من النواب الذين يمكن ان يكون قدوه همم
مثلا لا ليست مهمه كثيره المهم هو ان همم
الناحيه السياسيه همم في هذه المحطه التي
اريد ان يفرضها كيس سعيد
بقوه الدوله وبقوه الاجهزه الصلبه على شعب
التونسي هل ستحل هذه الانتخابات المشكله
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في تونس
الاجابه هي لا كل هذه الخطوات كلما تقدم
قيس سعيد في هذه همم
الاجنده الانقلابيه كل ما تعمقت ازمه
البلاد وهذا كنا نقوله منذ عام ونصف منذ
انقلاب 25% ونحن نقول انه كل ما تقدم كلما
مضى في هذا الاتجاه كلما مضى في اتجاه
بناء الاستبداد كلما تعمقت ازمه البلاد
ودفع الشعب التونسي الفاتوره غاليه ها هو
الشعب التونسي الان يدفع الفاتوره غاليه
ويدفع الفاتوره غاليه جدا الى درجه انه
يعني كفره الان كفره بمصار 25 جويليه وكفر
بقيس سعيد
وتخلى على دعمه واسناده وهذا رايناه على
مؤشرات كثيرا لا يمكن حصرها اخرها
الاستفتاء الفاشل الذي قام به وكذلك
عمليات صبر الاراء التي سبقت المرحله
الانتخابيه التي تؤكد ان الاغلبيه
التونسيه ولاول مره يقولون بان قيس سعيد
يقود البلاد في الاتجاه في الاتجاه الخطا
هذه الانتخابات لن تزيد سوى من التقسيم
المجتمع التونسي وتقسيم الشعب التونسي
اليوم هناك اتجاهين هناك اتجاه يقول بان
همم بانه على قيد سعيد ان يواصل في طريقه
وهذا بعض الاستثناءات بعض الاحزاب
الاستثنا ضعيفه غير المحسوبه التي تدعم
هذا التوجه ومن جهه اخرى
من التونسيين يرون بان مقام به قيس سعيد
همم انقلابا الان هذا المسار هو الذي في
الميزان
هل من خطه لديهم هذا من
نعم الخطه هي الان عندما يكون الشارع
التونسي امام هذه الازمه ويكون مجتمع
التونسي امام هذه الازمه وهمم هذا
الانقسام هو التحكيم التونسيين والتونسيات
في صناديق اقتراح نزيهه وشفافه
والديمقراطيه بمعايير همم بالمعايير
الدوليه انا اتحدى الانقلاب واتحدث سعيد
واتحدث كل انصار قيس سعيد ان نذهب وهذا
دليل على ان جبهه الخلاص والمعارضه لا
تخاف الانتخابات ولا تخاف صناديق الاقتراع
نحن القوه السياسيه الاساسيه ولكن لنذهب
الان الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه مبكرا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بما ان سعيد اختاره
لنفسه مساره وجزء من التونسيين يرفضون هذا
المسار هذا الانقسام كيف يمكن حسمه
عقلانيا بدون تحكيم الشعب التونسي حول هذا
السؤال الاساسي هل انت معه ان يواصل قيس
سعيد في اتجاهه ويمكن بذلك التجديد الثقه
في
همم وعندها ننحني لاراده التونسيين
والتونسيين الذي التي يعبرون عنها بسلام
التونسي
اقل من دقيقه اود ان اعود السيد جمال مارس
واسمع منه همم في اقل من دقيقه يعني حاله
التذمر من الواضح انها موجوده لدى الطبقه
السياسيه لدى الشعب الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه تنذر بما لا يبشر بخير للاسف
الشديد ماذا امام الرئيس التونسي من من
خيارات هل الى اي ماذا يمكن ربما احتواء
ما يبدو حاله تدمر عامه لدى تونسيه
من لقاءات قوه قيس علي سياده الكريم ان له
معارضه بهذه التعاسه تعاسه على مستوى
الخطاب خطاب خشبي خطاب يوجه الى الخارج
قبل الداخل
باب الصفرات صباحا مساء تعول على عزله
الدوليه لقيس سعيد ولكن للاسف بنسبه لها
طبعا ان قيس سعيد قد دول الحكومه الحاليه
قد عقدت مؤتمر ارتكاد في تونس عقدت القمه
الفرنكفونيه في جزيره جربه رئيس جمهوريه
كان منذ يوميه في العربيه السعوديه في قمه
صينيه عربيه ويتجه هذه الليله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الذي يعول عليها عملاء
في التيار الشعبي من الاحزاب المؤيده
للخيارات رئيس الصعيد كما اشكر جزيل الشكر
سيد جوهر بن مبارك اجابه الخلاص المعارضه
كنت ما معنا من تونس ختام وحلقتنا دمتم في
رعايه الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]